Portugal's Duro River Valley is unique a
UNESCO world heritage site it's where
all the world's port wine is produced
grown on cascading Terraces that date
back to the 1300s among the companies
producing their simmington family
estates stands out they bottle some of
the world's most famous port wines while
grappling with the reality of climate
change and as we found out doing all of
that while farming on the edge literally
the Portuguese named it the river of
gold
but it's these Vineyards built into
steep slopes and the port wine they
produce that is given the Duro River
Valley its wealth
without terracing these Hills are too
sleep really for cultivating the vine
and for the simmington family it's not
just a passion it's a centuries-old
business
in the business in the family so
currently there's three of the fourth
generation and we're six of the fifth
generation sibling Charlotte and Rob
simmington are part of that next
Generation those of us who work now in
the in the family business are all
descended from one of those three sons
they are carrying on a family tradition
that started in 1882 when their
great-great-grandfather Andrew
simmington landed in Portugal from
Scotland
since then simmington family estates has
become the largest producer of high
quality port wines in the world owning
Marquee Brands like Dows and Gramps the
official Port of choice for the late
Queen Elizabeth II many family
businesses don't make it this long yeah
how does it work we've been very lucky
to be honest we make it work between
Generations we all bring our different
strengths to the business I think the
simmingtons are known for working
extremely hard
and being quite diplomatic with each
other really yeah we're anglo-portuguese
so you know we've been here so long but
there's a sort of British pragmatism
that we bring to this
it's that British pragmatism that
started the portrait in the 1600s
constant war with France LED Merchants
to Portugal where they added Brandy to
red wine to help it survive the journey
back to England the wine was called Port
after the nearby city of Porto where it
was stored aged and shipped so I get the
impression that in the world of wine
Size Matters today the aging process is
done pretty much the same way
large Oak barrels are stacked to the
ceiling at the Graham's Port Lodge where
the wine will sometimes sit for decades
before being bottled and sold so this is
10 20 30 year old ports aging slowly in
Barrel slow oxidation Through the Wood
these are some of the most special ports
in the world because only time can do
this work there are no shortcuts this is
some of the oldest we have that passage
of time is on display in the family's
personal seller where Priceless bottles
dating back a century or more wait
patiently to be opened so this is like
the Family Jewels like we're never going
to sell this stuff this is either for
super special occasions
um or to be handed On to the Next
Generation
was that the alarm and there's
surprisingly well guarded
okay
the simmington's admit Port tends to be
a luxury drink and the average Drinker
closer in age to our grandparents but
they say taste are changing Porto's
booming and from a tourism perspective
so we get a much younger caliber of
people coming through here it's funny
because people come around be like oh I
don't really like port and we're like oh
try a chill glass of 20 year old Tony or
and the immediate reaction is always oh
I didn't know pork tasted like that we
decided to take our own taste test four
different types from the traditional so
should we start with a white let's start
with the white to a modern white port I
would imagine though that would go big
to a younger crowd exactly one of the
our biggest challenges is respecting our
past respecting ports Heritage and
tradition but bringing Port into the
21st century and you know with something
like this we've been able to do that
another challenge making sure their
business can survive a warming climate
these are vines that struggle and
produce fantastic wines as a result but
there is a limit so beyond which you
start to suffer in terms of quality
fortunately we're not at that limit yet
but we're seeing some warning signs the
Duro Valley saw a record high of 117
degrees this summer the effects of all
that extreme heat can be seen right here
with dried up leaves and grapes
literally dying on the vine some Growers
say that's caused their yields to be cut
by half how are you adapting and one of
the main initiatives is is planting two
great variety libraries in different
parts of the valley and we think we've
identified at least three which have the
potential to be scaled up as the climate
continues to go against us
when we visited back in August workers
had just begun harvesting this year's
crop the same way they've done for
hundreds of years by hand the only issue
the Harvest started a month early a
changing climate that Rob says has them
farming on the edge we need to use our
voices to say hey unless we turn this
thing around by the time our kids are
our age this thing might not be viable I
mean do you really see the possible end
of this business the forecasts are not
positive if motivation to protect the
things that we love is not enough in all
aspects of people's livelihoods and all
around the world what are we doing
because we're asleep at the wheel
asleep at the wheel you know it's it's a
business a family business that's lasted
well over 200 years they're doing
everything in their power to to ensure
that they conserve water that they you
know Terrace the right way
um you know they're a great family I
really enjoyed my time with them and
they they showed me something I didn't
expect I didn't expect to love port wine
oh this is white this is Graham's blend
number five well you guys take a sip it
is a joining of generations to the
benefit of both up next the unlikely
place they decided to put a preschool
and the remarkable effect it is having
[Music]
welcome back I get to sip now yeah you
don't like Port so I'm I'm like she said
in the piece I don't really like Port so
let me see so this is this is a pork
cocktail no this is a pork cut that's a
cocktail this is I like that and tonic
they they don't really sell this this in
the United States but I told them I said
you know I never had white pork before
and with a tonic it tastes just so
refreshing it is very refreshing can I
ask you a question
I don't know where are you that you were
going to drop the bottle of 18. that you
were trying to steal as the alarm was
bottle is worth fifty thousand dollars
or whatever because what because I
picked it up confidently you do know I'm
somewhat of a Butterfingers don't you um
I don't know I just trusted that I could
do it but wait Michelle what is this
white port taste like without the tonic
in it that's what I wanted to know I
really didn't want to taste you know it
would be like taking the bottle right
it's a sweet white wine it's a little
you know of a thick thicker consistency
but it's quite refreshing just you know
I'm not a red Port person I I'm big on
white port now I mean I never knew it
existed before this story
I'm I order it all right when I see it
on the menu nice and I say put some
tonic in there and then a sprig of mints
and drink secrets from Michelle
bartender